while Jim Hammond went forward as a
human torch coming to grips with
society's view of him and the Atlantic
Ocean another superpower being was
emerging a human Atlantean hybrid in the
years leading up to World War two the
United Kingdom's Prime Minister Winston
Churchill had sought to capture
vibranium as a material used for weapons
against the Axis powers instructing
English explorer Ernest Shackleton to
search the Atlantic during their
explorations the ship was lost and
Ernest was presumed dead Antony to
capitalize on the UK's venture and
proceed of advancing their own weapons
program in the twilight of his life u.s.
President Woodrow Wilson had instructed
Leonard Mackenzie to continue the search
taking to the Atlantic and conducting a
series of explosions on the ice
Mackenzie's actions caught the attention
of Atlantean King Thakur who instructed
his daughter Finn to investigate stowing
a Boer Mackenzie's ship and being taken
prisoner miss time progressed Mackenzie
and Finn fell in love however on the day
of their marriage the ship of Mackenzie
was attacked by Atlanteans under the
orders of retrieving princess Finn and
when Leonard was believed dead Finn
returned to her Kingdom pregnant with
Leonard's child christening her son name
were his early years were spent learning
about his mixed heritage leading to a
curiosity about the surface world
however when the Nazis learned a
vibranium zigzoo the rare metal for
their own uses their explorations and
near discovery of Atlantis led Namor to
take up arms against Hitler and his
forces within the United States itself
the newly formed Captain America was
rising as a symbol for the American
people and the Allied powers
representing the principle of freedom
and the sacrifices that came with it and
the eyes of military personnel Steve
Rogers conviction was his weakness
believing that there were times when
torture and killing was necessary and an
effort to ensure their plans for
espionage and subterfuge were carried
out Rogers was partnered with a teenage
boy named James Buchanan Barnes
losing his mother in childbirth and his
father to a training accident Bucky was
trained as a black ops agent with
emphasis on torture and stealth fighting
alongside Captain America name with a
submariner and Jim Hammond the Human
Torch
the group named themselves the invaders
and led a series of campaigns to thwart
the Nazi regime however the Nazis
themselves were not without their own
secret weapon continuing his tutelage
under the direction of Adolf Hitler
Johann Schmidt came to view aid off as a
hindrance to his goal of world
domination assassinating Hitler's
closest advisors and positioning himself
as a second most powerful person in
Germany even Hitler himself came to fear
Johan due to his ruthlessness and
cunning believing the world domination
would require a collaborative effort far
beyond Hitler's primitive views Johan
turned his sights to the legendary
general Baron von Strucker a signing
Strucker to the far east johan's
intention was to form a pact with the
japanese mystics known as the hand using
their magic to complement Germany's
military tactics and by combining their
forces a sub sect of the hand joined
Baron von Strucker giving birth to the
second iteration of Hydra back in
Germany proper the Third Reich had
already begun a series of campaigns
aimed at eliminating the Jewish
population where this included the now
infamous final solution the desire of
Nazis to remove undesirables had
unexpected consequences most notably the
emergence of one of Earth's most
powerful mutants the son of a former
Jewish soldier turned watchmaker max
Eisen Hart's father and grandfather had
viewed their state in life his temporary
believing that their displacement within
the Warsaw Ghetto would give way to the
return to a life of normalcy at the
war's conclusion however whether this
view was held through a refusal to
acknowledge the truth or a genuine
belief varies but this perception was
ultimately shattered when the Nazis
began transporting the inhabitants of
the Warsaw Ghetto
to the Treblinka extermination camp
escaping from their captors with the
intention of taking refuge in a safe
house for German Jews max was forced to
bear witness as his family was
systematically murdered by Nazi soldiers
and thrown into a mass grave taken to
the Auschwitz concentration camp max was
assigned to the Sonderkommando
tasked with cleaning out the cremation
ovens and gas chambers while destroying
the bodies are those exterminated by the
Nazis coming to grips with the brutality
of humans Max's experience shaped him on
a fundamental level but the truth was
far more terrifying than fiction with
his genetic manipulations by apocalypse
mr. sinister used his longevity to
experiment on humans in an effort to
understand the human genome viewing
concentration camps as the perfect
setting to conduct these experiments
without question the fledgling mutant
community within Auschwitz saw their
bodies mutilated through gruesome
experiments remaining woefully unaware
of the doctors true identity and using
his experience as a small-time smuggler
of goods within the Warsaw Ghetto max
eased as harsh existence within ash
woods by bribing the guards with goods
unavailable through conventional means
reuniting with his childhood crush Magda
during his time in Auschwitz max Magda
and other members of the concentration
camp alongside rebels on the outside
intended to launch a revolution freeing
themselves from the yoke of oppression
coinciding with the arrival of Captain
America Bucky Namor and Jim Hammond as
they cut a swath in the German front max
and Magda used the auschwitz revolution
to escape and made their way to the
Carpathian Mountains where they began
their life together in marriage
while world war two raged on the forces
of Captain America Bucky name with a
submariner in Jim Hammond carried out a
series of campaigns on behalf of the
Allied powers taking them to the
farthest corners of the world these acts
were in and of themselves targeted at
stopping the Nazi advancement
transitioning to northern Africa
despite his blunder and allowing the
Allied forces to invade Normandy
Erwin Rommel was still considered to be
one of Hitler's highest-ranking generals
leading a campaign to take wakanda's
vibranium stores despite his advanced
weaponry
the wakandans were unable to hold off
the forces of Rommel for any real
measure of time as a result the invaders
were successful in defeating the Nazis
under Ramos command and Rogers was
rewarded with the shard of vibranium
Commission aid the intelligence branch
of the United States to develop a new
shield during the process one of its
scientists quite literally fell asleep
waking up to a medal of indestructible
composition in the shape of a perfect
circle providing Captain America with
the shield he desired under the
direction of the US government the
scientists went forward attempting to
recreate the alloy
with a suicide of Adolf Hitler marking
the beginning of the end for the Third
Reich not all of his forces went quietly
as the top scientists under the Nazi
regime Baron Zemo stood is the 12th
generation in his family's line to carry
the name drawing the attention of the
Allied powers owing to his creation of
the Medusa effect a weapon capable of
annihilating the entirety of the United
States Army Air Forces the invaders were
tasked with bringing down Zemo and
taking him into allied custody however
after invading his fortress and
attempting to destroy a drone plane the
ensuing conflict saw both Steve Rogers
and Bucky Barnes thrown into the icy
waters of the English Channel
while Rogers would be frozen in
suspended animation for several decades
Bucky Barnes was not so lucky with the
Russian government looking to the
premise of Captain America the communist
regime intended to launch its own super
soldier program while one half of the
government targeted his fledgling mutant
community looking to brainwash them into
subservience the body of Bucky Barnes
was located and taken by KGB general
Alexander Lucan concluding that both
Rogers and Barnes had been killed in
action
the US government needed a response
believing that if the American people
learned of Rogers and Barnes death that
the moral compass for the last vestiges
of the war effort would crumble because
the US and Russia were running headlong
into the Cold War the US government
chose to appoint a series of successors
operating under the mantles of Captain
America and Bucky Barnes with a public
failing to know the difference in their
mind Steve Rogers remained a staunch
protector for all they held dear across
the Atlantic in upstate New York a young
Charles Xavier was coping with radical
changes in his life born to Brian and
Sharon Xavier the life of Charles was
part and parcel to government
experimentation continuing his schemes
and understanding the mutant and human
genomes mr. sinister long life allowed
for a multitude of schemes and plans
while the fall of Auschwitz led to the
abandonment of his experimentation
without question his ability to alter
his own physical appearance allowed for
integration into the scientific
community using less than savory methods
using Brian Xavier and his partner Kurt
Marko as unwitting accomplices the to
use the resources of the United States
government to analyze the genes of
mutants providing considerable
compensation for their efforts
when Brian Xavier died in an explosion
Charon inherited this wealth along with
Kurt's affections aunt ending to make
his way into the marriage bed Kurt was a
cruel father to his biological son Kane
instead showing affection to Charles
however this was revealed to be a ruse
by Kurt who would used the motivation of
ensuring that he inherited all of
Sharon's wealth nevertheless Kurt's
perceived doting on Charles led to a
bitter hatred from Kane which was
compounded by the act of accidentally
killing his father and learning that
Charles Xavier
possessed the power to read minds while
this would mark a drastic change in the
life of Charles Xavier as beau he and
Kane went forward bitter enemies
unbeknownst to either of these men the
earth and the rest of the universe's
inhabitants existence as they knew it
was only one part of a larger experiment
it began in the realm beyond the
multiverse home to the ivory kings these
white lords from wild space were nothing
if not curious operating with unknown
origins and unmatched power at some
point in the past the beyonders took
notice of the multiverse and the
denizens has will in restrict it to a
dimension devoid of time but part and
parcel to the space itself the beyonders
found a nonlinear existence to be
something of intrigue what was time what
was death and what was life what did it
mean to be both an individual and part
of a larger whole and tending to find
answers to their questions by launching
a grand experiment the beyonders set in
motion a series of events which could
not be undone
[Music]
I'd make people not hate each other
because of their religion because of
their nationality because of any stupid
reason if we could abolish hatred we
live on this gorgeous planet there's a
character I wrote called the Silver
Surfer and I always had him making those
kind of remarks philosophical things
about he was from another world and he
said why don't we realize we're on a
planet that gives us everything food
beautiful weather
Sun everything why don't we enjoy it why
do we spend time fighting and hating
each other I loved writing the Silver
Surfer
[Music]
you